fan man is a voice you rings of power
and now you've done The Witcher prequel
did you decide when did you decide you
wanted to just dominate comic-cons
make all the money in the world well I
really listen if I was Robert Downey Jr
we wouldn't even be having this
conversation someone else could do my
interviews for me but I I love this this
wheelhouse this whole fantasy sword and
sorcery sci-fi area is my jam I've been
reading comics and graphic novels and
watching TV shows like this since I was
eight so for me nobody in my family is
surprised oh then he's playing an evil
wizard with a big staff and a magic
trick all right yes so nobody's
surprised at this so it's a joy for me
to be in this incredibly detailed
beautifully production design
beautifully active world uh Joe question
for you um when did you find out you
were going to be playing a key component
if you will of the of the prequel
um or during the whilst there was
shooting the prequel they came to me and
we actually shot a scene a small little
scene which was your last day of
shooting and I kind of and everyone was
like kind of crawling out the door very
tired and exhausted after a very very
long shoot and I came in going hey guys
I'm gonna sing a little song and then we
later went on to reshoot and rewrite
that whole sequence to create uh the
opening that we see in the show now
um and so yeah it kind of was like an
ongoing process that that I just kind of
just found myself in I just it's really
good it's a it's a pro viewer opening
sequence I think well I mean if they're
like The Witcher they're going to love
they're going to love you though they're
going to love you team the whole thing
off I think they're going to love every
cast member that's the thing that's been
like absolutely lodged in my heart since
watching the show was was seeing
everyone commit with this new energy and
uh I was gutted I'm not in it more I
just wanted to hang out with everyone it
looked like everyone was just having the
best time as well for both of you I love
learning about like the behind the
scenes of the making of a show so what
do you think might surprise fans of The
Witcher to like learn about what goes on
behind the scenes in the making of
something like this or even The Witcher
the main series
from blood origin
um points of view
Balor and Eridan relaxing in David Bowie
songs in between takes you could hear
fashion The Laughing gnome changes Jacob
is very skilled at doing any Bowie voice
I was very much into Bob Marley there's
a lot of singing going on yeah what do
you do in between in between things it's
usually me and uh Henry or Anya just
kind of you we end up making the
weirdest games I think there was one
game during season three when it was
about four o'clock in the morning where
we had to think of the least insulting
insults that uh and so I think uh do you
have an example I think I said that
Henry had small hair at some point you
know what I mean just really dumb things
to your ears are like tomatoes exactly
yeah and that kind of keeps us going on
those long hard nights yeah I think
people don't realize sometimes it's not
as glamorous behind the scenes when
you're working a 16-hour day yeah yeah
because when you're talking to a tennis
ball all day or a mark on a wall yeah
you've got to figure out a way to have
some fun yeah otherwise you'll Keel over
and then when I need to stop I'm just
gonna say congrats and good luck with
the rest of your speed dating thank you
thank you